books good evening my name's captain
Dori corner at the Los Vegas
metropolitan Police Department that
spelled e o R I last name is spelled Kor
en I just wanted to provide a brief
update on the current situation that I
discussed earlier this evening we are
still dealing with some protesters on
Las Vegas Boulevard but that number has
shrinked quite a bit we've made
approximately 30 to 40 arrests thus far
that number is still fluctuating so
please bear with us as we get you a more
accurate number once we have better
information we also have two officers
that have been injured during this
evening one was transported to the
hospital with a hand injury and the
other was not transported his injury was
minor enough didn't require transport
again the PERT persons that are being
arrested are those that are violating
the law those are that are making the
situation unsafe and I just want to
reiterate to the community and to the
protesters that are involved in this
evening in particular that we support
your First Amendment right to protest
but we ask you to please obey the laws
and keep this safe for everyone it's in
our best interest for this whole city to
reopen safely and get back to a strong
economy and we are all in the same
position to try to make that happen so
we ask people that want to express their
First Amendment rights and want a
protest please just do so safely and we
will support that 100% and then of
course if you are violating the law or
you are making it unsafe for yourself
your others or for the police then we
will have to take action and make it
safe
so the first officer that was
transported to the hospital has a hand
injury that required transport don't
have much of an information in terms of
the status of that the second officer
was a minor injury so he did not require
transport the first or one of the
officers was hurt while engaging with
the protesters we don't have the
specifics but some of the protesters
were throwing things at the officers and
that may have been one of the causes but
we're still evaluating the situation so
those that are being detained and
arrested or do our mainly doing so or
they're being arrested for violating a
dispersal order so at the end of the day
if we've offered and we've given many
many opportunities for the protesters to
disperse the only time that this
personal order is given is if they
become unruly and start violating other
laws so violating traffic laws or
harming officers or harming other
citizens anything of the sort that would
be a violation of the law and a safety
matter at that point we would issue a
dispersal order we usually give multiple
dispersal orders wait enough time for
people to leave a lot of law-abiding
citizens that just want to protest
peacefully they do leave and they don't
want anything to do with the violence
they just want to be here and express
their First Amendment rights those that
stay and want to continue to violate the
law those are the ones that arrested
we've done our best to be in contact
with those organizing but this tonight's
event had a mixture of different groups
that were here we don't believe that
there was just one person responsible
for organizing this entire event but we
have tried our best to communicate with
those individuals express our concerns
also our solidarity and where we stand
with supporting some of the issues that
are happening right now across the
country but ultimately some of that
communication only goes to certain
people and then others who don't
necessarily care to to communicate with
the police have moved forward with what
they did tonight
I'm sorry I don't have any information
on that but I can tell you with
confidence that we only arrest those
individuals who are breaking the law and
in addition when they're breaking the
law in this particular case it's because
it's also a safety issue there have been
some individuals who were initially
detained and then cited and released but
a lot of the other individuals are being
arrested and going to jail because of
the level of violation or the level of
violence that escalated later through
the night but I just like to just again
remind the community that we will
certainly support everyone's First
Amendment rights or any other
constitutional protected activities we
encourage people to continue to if they
want a protest to protest peacefully but
at the same time we have to protect our
community we've formed this concept of
Vegas strong and it's important that we
embody that to protect all of our
community including our police officers
including the public that's out there so
please just those that are out there
continue to obey the law and we'll do
the best we can to support you thank you
you